S'il faut mourir un jour
Je veux que tu sois là
Car c'est ton amour
Qui m'aidera à m'en aller
Vers l'au-delà
Alors je partirai
Sans peur et sans regrets
Et dans mon délire, je revivrai toute une vie de souvenirs
Pour traverser le miroir
Je ne veux que ton regard
Pour mon voyage sans retour
Mourir auprès de mon amour
Et m'endormir sur ton sourire
Le temps qui nous poursuit
Ne peut nous séparer
Même après la vie
Nos joies passées vont nous unir à l'infini
Pour m'enfoncer dans la nuit
Et renoncer à la vie
Je veux dans tes bras qui m'entourent
Mourir auprès de mon amour
Et m'endormir sur ton sourire
Pour traverser le miroir
Je ne veux que ton regard
Pour mon voyage sans retour
Mourir auprès de mon amour
Et m'endormir sur ton sourire.